i started to pay very careful attention
to
what i was saying i don't know if that
happened voluntarily or involuntarily
but i could feel a sort of split
developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing that
has happened to them
after they've listened to some of the
material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me
that was talking a lot and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging and the part that
was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95
of what i was saying and so then i
didn't really know what to do i thought
okay this is strange so
maybe i've fragmented and that's just
not a good thing at all
i mean it wasn't like i was hearing
voices or anything like that i mean
it wasn't like that it was it was
well people have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like well which of these
two things are me is it the part that's
listening and saying
no that's rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal
verbal business me and i didn't know but
i decided i would go with the critic
and then what i'd tried to do what i
learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk whether or not the
words that i'm saying are either making
me align or making me come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment
is i think alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because i think if
you say
things that are as true as you can say
them let's say
then they come up they come out of the
depths
inside of you because we don't know
where thoughts come from we don't know
how
far down into your substructure the
thoughts emerge we don't know what
processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being
we don't understand any of that we don't
even conceptualize that but i believe
that you can feel
that and i learned some of that from
reading carl rogers by the way who's a
great clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as the coherence between the
the the spiritual or the or the abstract
and the physical that the two things
were aligned
and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing
not saying things that would make me
weak and what happened was that i had to
stop
saying almost everything that i was
saying i would say 95
of it as a hell of a shock to wake up
and i mean
this was over a few months but it's a
hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that
you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock you know and you might
think well do you really want all of
that to burn off it's like well there's
nothing left but a little husk five
percent of you it's like well
if that five percent is solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen the next best predictor
of lifetime success is conscientiousness
well so and of tho of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say
orderliness and and industriousness the
better predictor is industriousness
so the question is well what can you do
about your industriousness
and the answer to that is well that's
kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits
this is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes i think the
best thing you can do with regards to
your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that
and basically it does a situational
analysis of
it helps you do a situational analysis
of your life more than a psychological
analysis i would say and so
the questions are something like well
all right you're going to have to put
some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so
what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them
in the big five manner you know if
you're extroverted you want friends if
you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship
if you're disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation
that you could draw on that you could
tailor to your own you know your own
personality
but then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across and so
we ask people about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself
properly you know what would you want
from your friendships what would you
want from your intimate relationship how
would you like to structure your family
what do you want for your career well
how are you going to use your time
outside of your
job and how are you going to regulate
your mental physical
mental and physical health and maybe
also your drug and alcohol use because
that's
that's
a good place to auger down you know
because alcoholism for example wipes out
you know five to ten percent of people
so you want to keep that
under control and then and then so maybe
you know you you you develop a vision of
what your life what you would like your
life to be
and that associates the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down
the goal into micro processes that you
can implement the micro processes become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their
uh causal association with the goal
and that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward
and the way it works is that it works
better if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation
working out and so the more valuable the
goal in principle the more the micro
processes associated with that goal
start to take on a positive charge and
so what that means is while you get up
in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified
to fail as well as excited about
succeeding because that's also useful
you specify your goal you do that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want
you want to specify goals that make you
say oh
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts it would clearly be
worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy
the question is why would you ever do
anything and the answer that has to be
because you've determined
by some means that it's worthwhile and
then the next
question might be well where should you
look for worthwhile things and one would
be well you could consult your own
temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends
like you don't need to have all these
things but you better have most of them
family friends career educational goals
plans for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad that's a bad deal
for you so so once
but once you set up that that goal
structure let's say and that's really in
many
in many ways that's what you should be
doing at universities is that's exactly
what you should be doing is trying to
figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
you use everything you learned
as a means of building that person that
you want to be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly and this is
back down to the micro routine analysis
so i saying well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious
okay number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure
so if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy which is real easy
because that's just a matter of not
doing as well then you don't know when
you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful
so i'll keep myself blind about when i
fail that's fine except you'll fail all
the time then
you just won't know it until you've
failed so badly that you're done
and that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
so so i would recommend that you don't
let that happen
so that's willful blindness right you
could have known but you chose not to
okay so once you get your goal structure
set up you think okay if i could have
this
life it looks like that might be worth
living despite the fact that it's going
to be
you know anxiety provoking and
threatening and there's going to be some
suffering and loss involved in all of
that
obviously the goal is to to have a
vision for your life
such that all things considered that
justifies your effort
make a damn schedule and stick to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule
it's not a bloody prison that's the
first thing that people do wrong they
say well i don't like to have follow a
schedule
it's like well what kind of schedule are
you setting up well i should i have to
do this then i have to do this then i
have to do this
you know and then i just go play video
games because who wants to do all these
things that i have to do
it's like wrong set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow
if i was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day i could have
practically speaking what would it look
like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day
you're not in worse shape than you were
that than at the beginning of the day
right because that's a stupid day
if you have a bunch of those in a row
you just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are
but even that you can you can ask
yourself okay well i've got these
responsibilities
i have to schedule the damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you gotta
work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
gonna do for me that makes it likely
that i'll work for you
well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you
do an hour of responsibility and then
you play a video game for 15 minutes i
don't know whatever turns your crank
man but you know you have to negotiate
with yourself and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70
accuracy but that beats the hell out of
zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy
another rule is well aim for 51 the next
week or 50 and a half
percent for god's sake or because you're
you're going to hit
that position where things start to loop
back positively and spiral you upward i
had a plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and
he had put in all the plastic piping you
know and i was going to test the joints
they're supposed to be glued together
with this pipe glue right
and i said i told him i had to test the
joints and he said well you don't have
to test my joints they never leak and i
thought yeah
that's okay how about if i test them so
i went up on the
third floor and filled the pipes with
water capping them in the basement like
you're supposed to
like half an hour later i had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints
that was the night before the drywallers
were supposed to show up
so well so he wasn't particularly
competent that's the point of that story
but even more so
he had put a bunch of the plastic pipe
outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night
you know sawing through plastic pipe and
re-gluing joints so that
my well so that the dry rollers could
come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble
we don't need people to cause more
trouble we need people to solve
problems you know and so you can be a
tradesman and you can be you can make a
lot of money as a tradesperson it's a
bloody
reliable honorable forthright
productive way of making a living and
there is a hell of a lot of difference
between a working man who knows what
he's doing
and one who doesn't both in terms of
skill and ethics
right and you work with someone who
knows what they're doing it's a bloody
pleasure
they tell you what they're going to do
they tell you how much it will cost
they go and do it it works and you pay
them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence
and so you listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people
it's not such a terrible thing man maybe
you wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible
most people aren't but that doesn't mean
there isn't something you could be great
at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top
you know flap about uselessly and whine
about your life
it's not helpful it'll just make you
miserable you're not reliable to anyone
you can't help out in a crisis
it's like so you tell young people and
this is another message for
conservatives like
i don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for god's sake be an honest
person
and work and get to the top of whatever
it is that you want to get to the top
of you know and and and and stand up for
yourself like a respectable human being
and
be a bit of a light on the world instead
of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's
it's painful to watch they're so
relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself
see if you can learn to tell the truth
concentrate on something for a year or
two
you could be a bloody world beater they
think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting
that might make life for life worth
living it's like yeah it might so
why don't you go do it that's what the
damn universities were supposed to be
teaching people they've forgotten that
i went to harvard a month ago a month
and a half i used to teach there
and i talked to a bunch of students you
know and i told them it's not easy to
get into harvard you know
like you're a valedictorian if you're at
harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian
you're way better than most people at at
least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the
acceptance rate is like five percent and
believe me not everybody applies so
it's a very selective school and so why
am i saying that it's like
these are high quality kids so i told
them what i just told you it's like
here you are at harvard it's like get
yourself educated man
read some books learn to talk learn to
think make yourself into something
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here
happy that you were put there in that
great institution
you know and they came up to me
afterwards and said
god i wish someone would have told us
that when we were in our first
year it's like jesus why didn't someone
tell them that
for god's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest university in the world
is it so difficult to figure that out
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak
when you had opportunity to go out and
explore
or withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid
so it's not only that you were over
protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity
you know so maybe you're a kid in the
playground right and you're having some
trouble with other kids
and you know in the back of your mind i
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene
and you know that that's not right you
know that you're breaking the social
contract
but it's easier and so that's what you
do you run off to an authority figure
and hide behind the great father right
roughly speaking
well the problem with that is you don't
learn how to do it yourself
so then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40.
so then you take people out you say well
what are you afraid of rank it from one
to ten
so ten is make a list of ten things
you're afraid of
the least the thing you're least afraid
of we'll call number ten
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death
open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage you find out
you go do that
it works you're nervous as hell
especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death
that's what you've learned and then you
move a little closer and then you move a
little closer and then you move a little
closer and finally you're back in
what's no longer the elevator from a
symbolic perspective it's a tomb right
it's
it's it's a place of enclosure and
isolation
and you learn turns out i can withstand
that
and then you're met much more together
much more confident
and that's often one of the things that
often happens in situations like that
i've seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up
they'll often start standing up to
people around them in a way they never
did before i talked to people about
um taking care of themselves like
they're someone
who they have responsibility for and
that's not a political issue too it's
it's uh it's an injunction to
assuming that you have a certain
intrinsic value
you know and that it's necessary for
that value to manifest itself
for you to push yourself against the
world to challenge yourself because
otherwise
what you're capable of won't manifest
itself it has to be
developed it has to be called forth by
necessity right you have to pick a hard
problem and try to solve it and push
yourself against it
in order for and you have to try to do
that truthfully and responsibly
in order for what it is that you're
intrinsically
capable of and composed of to come to
the forefront
and that seems like a very positive
thing as far as i'm concerned to
encourage people to be responsible for
themselves and for other people and also
to point out that
that you have a moral responsibility to
do so
for yourself just as you do for others
and
i i think that that message has been
very
helpful to people at least that's what
they've told me
the i and it's predicated that the rule
is predicated on
the old judeo-christian idea the oldest
idea in some sense that
you know that there's a relationship
between
logos which is truthful speech and
communication and
bringing things into being from chaotic
potential that's
the idea that's put forward in genesis
and also the idea that men
and women alike are made in the image of
god which suggests that
like god we have the capability of
affecting potential affecting the
possible future and turning it into the
actual present and that we do that
at least in part as a consequence of our
ethical choices
the more radical the necessary change
the more pain that accompanies it
like the more opportunity as well but
and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully
and so it's not surprising that people
shrink away from learning
we learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man
like it took you out and so the fact
that people flee from that is hardly
surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better the better idea is to
eat a little poison every day so that
you don't have to overdose in a month
it's something like that and it is the
case that
i think because you don't you aren't
forced first of all you don't learn
unless you're forced to learn
i know there's alternatives to that
there's the voluntary search for
knowledge
and that's a fine thing and that is an
antidote to this
but apart from that speaking more
practically you tend not to learn unless
you're forced to learn and
it's and what you tend to learn by force
are difficult lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you it's because maybe
it's because they're convinced that
there's some way of forestalling the
necessary learning
and there isn't any way of forestalling
it
all you do is make it worse in the
future you make yourself smaller
and you make the lesson harder and so
that's why in so many
religious doctrines there's emphasis on
humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that you don't know
enough so that your life isn't going to
be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way
you should take it as fast as you can
but you have to have a very
tragic i would say view of reality and
also a harsh one because it's not just
tragedy it's also malevolence you have
to understand that those are waiting for
you
and that makes you desperate enough to
learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but that's that's a hard way of looking
at the world
it beats living through it though when i
was 25 or so i
probably weighed about 138 pounds i
smoked like
packed cigarettes day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and
you know there were long winters there
and my friends were heavy drinkers and
most of them dropped out of school by
the time they were 15 or 16 went off to
work on the oil rigs and
you know it was a rough town and we
drank a lot i started when i was 14 and
you know um and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also
still intellectually obsessed by as i am
now
and uh so that would have been that
would have been in 85 but when i
but i decided around that about 85 84
something like that maybe a little
earlier that i was really going to try
to get my act together
and so i started doing that i
you know i first of all i i quit smoking
oh that took a long time because i
eventually had to quit drinking too in
order to quit smoking and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done i had a fine
time when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined i had
to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them
really you know obsessively since i was
probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point
around 25 when i was in graduate school
trying to get my phds doing all my
research like i published 15 papers by
the time i
graduated with my phd which was by i
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any un
graduate student at that time had ever
published at mcgill i think that's right
might have been twice as many or maybe
twice as many maybe even three times as
many and at the same time i wrote maps
of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because i was writing about
three hours a day doing that and
i couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my
sort of my what what would you say my
my my hedonistic my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up
and also work seriously on the issues
that were at hand so
you know i had to stop that's a
sacrifice i had to stop
messing about and straight myself out if
you want to watch the affirmations video
we did with wim hof
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there just because
people
believe the wrong things they believe in
pills who believe in medicines
they believe depression cannot be
tackled they believe
you cannot enter into your brain